ensuite le contexte social du pays nous
oblige tous collectivement notre
avertissement est clair enlever un euro
de pouvoir d'achat aux Français qui
travaillent ou aux retraités seraient
d'une injustice presque sinite nous nous
y opposerons de toutes nos forces comme
nous l'avons fait à l'Assemblée
nationale où les propositions en matière
de taxes d'impôts de cotisation ont été
nombreuses on nous a proposé de taxer
les heures supplémentaires alors même
qu'un ouvrier sur deux dans notre pays
fait des heures supplémentaires on nous
a proposé de taxer les petites
successions dans notre pays 80% des
successions sont aujourd'hui exonérées
d'impôts les amendements venus de la
nupaisse nous proposaient de taxer
toutes les successions dès le premier
euro y compris les petites successions à
30000 40000 euros de Français qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie dont le travail
a été taxé toute leur vie et qui aurait
été à nouveau taxé au moment de la
succession on nous a proposé d'augmenter
les charges pour les petits artisans les
petits commerçants les petits chefs
d'entreprise 700 euros de plus pour un
salarié au SMIC de charge c'est ce qui
était proposé à l'Assemblée nationale
cela voudrait dire que pour un boulanger
qui emploie trois salariés au SMIC il
aurait dû en licencier un pour payer les
charges des deux autres qui étaient
proposés dans les amendements c'est
exactement les propositions qui nous ont
été faites mais je vois qu'elles ont
aussi leur défenseur ici notre
conviction
notre conviction c'est que c'est le
travail qui crée la richesse pas les
nouveaux impôts enfin
enfin notre système actuel est injuste
et il faut le corriger
[Musique]